"Mathematik ist die Sprache des Universums"
- Das wird zumindest immer wieder behauptet.
Egal wo man hinblickt oder sich befindet, mit Mathe kann man die Natur beschreiben.
Und obwohl wir vielleicht in einem Universum leben,
in dem es so etwas wie Zufall gar nicht geben könnte,
können uns Wahrscheinlichkeiten eine Menge verraten
wie dieses Gedankenexperiment zeigt:
[Untertitel von MacMarc]
Stellt euch vor wir reisen mit einem Portal in eine andere Dimension
- nennen wir sie Dimension C-137 -
wir wissen nichts über diesen
alternativen Zeitstrang unserer Welt
also beginnen wir diese Welt zu erkunden
wir stoßen auf einen Computer,
also kann sich dieses Universum nicht allzu sehr von unserem unterscheiden.
Immerhin muss es Mikrochips,
Elektrizität und tausende andere Dinge dafür geben.
Wir öffnen Wikipedia, also gibt es auch das Internet und Wikipedia selber
und klicken auf "zufälliger
Artikel",
um zu sehen was die Universum noch zu bieten hat
Wir landen auf der Seite zum 17. Star Wars-Film.
Okay, also gibt es hier schon mehr als in unserem Universum.
Aber jetzt wird es interessant:
Gibt es eine Möglichkeit nur anhand dieser Zahl, 17, herauszufinden,
wie viele Star Wars-Filme in dieser Dimenstion insgesamt gedreht wurden?
Das ist das "German Tank Problem"
oder auf deutsch "das deutsche Panzerproblem".
Denn während des 2. Weltkriegs
sind die Alliierten auf ein ganz ähnliches Problem gestoßen.
Sie wollten wissen, wie viele deutsche Panzer
jeden Monat produziert werden.
Die einzige Informationsquelle, die sie hatten,
waren die nummerierten deutschen Panzer,
die immer mal wieder gesichtet wurden.
Und überraschender Weise bieten einem komplett zufällige Zahlen
sehr viele Informationen.
Findet man zum Beispiel einen Panzer mit der Nummer 217,
kann man daraus direkt zwei Dinge schließen:
Zum einen, dass es mindestens 217 Panzer geben muss,
vorausgesetzt, dass die Panzer fortlaufend durchnummeriert werden.
Und zum anderen kann man allein von dieser Zahl ausgehend
erste Schätzungen über die maximale Anzahl der Panzer machen.
Zum Beispiel ist es extrem unwahrscheinlich, dass jeden Monat
mehrere Millionen Panzer produziert werden.
Die Chance, dass wir bei diesen Zahlen
einen dreistellig nummerierten Panzer finden
ist sehr unwahrscheinlich.
Okay, dass die Deutschen nicht Millionen Panzer herstellen,
hätte man sich wahrscheinlich auch so denken können.
Aber man kann jetzt schon eine Wahrscheinlichkeitsverteilung aufstellen
und zwar mit der einfachen Formel "1 durch x"
Wir ihr sehen könnt, ist es am wahrscheinlichsten,
dass es 217 Panzer gibt.
Möchte man aber möglichst nah am Durchschnitt sein,
sollte man seine Zahl verdoppeln.
Das ergibt auch Sinn, wenn man nur eine einzige Zahl kennt
und einem alles andere unbekannt ist.
Man nimmt einfach an, dass man sich exakt in der Mitte befindet
und verdoppelt um auf den maximalen Wert zu kommen.
Aber jetzt wird es wirklich cool,
denn wir bekommen mehr Informationen:
Ein zweiter deutscher Panzer wurde gesichtet
und er hatte die Nummer 91.
Auf den ersten Blick ändert sich durch diese neue Information nichts,
denn unsere minimale Anzahl an Panzern ist weiterhin 217.
Aber 91 ist in einem ähnlichen Bereich wie unsere erste Zahl
und untermauert weiter unsere Vermutung,
dass die Anzahl der produzierten Panzer in den Hunderten
und nicht in den Tausenden oder sogar noch darüber liegt.
Wir können diese beiden Informationen jetzt miteinander multiplizieren
und erhalten - hier in rot - unsere erneuerte
Wahrscheinlichkeit für die maximale
Anzahl der produzierten Panzer. Am
wahrscheinlichsten ist immer noch, dass
es insgesamt 217 Panzer gibt, aber die
neue Information hat die
Wahrscheinlichkeit, dass die maximale
Anzahl in den hohen Hunderten liegt, stark
nach unten gedrückt
Je mehr Informationen wir bekommen, 256, 248, 61, desto genauer wird
unsere Wahrscheinlichkeitsverteilung. Bis
wir uns irgendwann sehr sicher sein
können, dass die Anzahl der produzierten
Panzer irgendwo zwischen 256 und 300 liegt.
Und so war es auch: Nach Ende des Krieges konnten die Alliierten ihre Berechnungen
mit den Aufzeichnungen der Nazis
vergleichen und sehen, dass die
Wahrscheinlichkeitsrechnung fast schon
beängstigend genau war. Und das im
Vergleich zu Schätzungen vieler
Experten, die sich nie einig waren
ob die Deutschen nun 100 oder 1000 Panzer produzieren würden. Und seitdem benutzen nur
die wenigsten Staaten oder Unternehmen
noch fortlaufende Seriennummern für
irgendetwas, das auch nur halbwegs
geheim ist. Vor einigen Jahren benutzte Apple
noch einmal fortlaufende Nummern für
ihre iPhones und mit nur 40 Seriennummern
konnte ein Blogger die Anzahl der verkauften Telefone fast exakt berechnen.
Und das alles durch die Kraft des
Zufalls, der durch seine
Unberechenbarkeit berechenbar wird,
paradox eigentlich. Aber es ist nicht
das einzige Paradoxon in der Wahrscheinlichkeit
Das ist die gaußsche Normalverteilung, die viele von uns aus
der schule kennen dürften. Diese kurve
tritt sehr häufig auf, wenn um einen
Vorgang herum
Zufälle in beide Richtungen auftreten.
Zum Beispiel bei einer Klassenarbeit, bei
der Massenproduktion von Gegenständen oder wenn Dinge ausgemessen werden.
Und was hier rot eingezeichnet ist, ist
die Standardabweichung, das sind die 68% der Fälle die am nächsten am
Mittelwert liegen.
Das heißt, wenn ich zum Beispiel zu
den 68% der Menschen gehöre, die
um den Mittelwert von, sagen wir einmal
Körpergröße, liegen - bei Männern 1,78 Meter
dann bin ich mathematisch betrachtet "normal".
die Spanne umfasst hier umfasst hier ungefähr 5 cm in jede Richtung
Bedeutet, dass ich zwischen 1,73 und 1,83 Meter
groß sein muss, um normal groß zu sein.
Für Frauen sind das übrigens 1,60 bis 1,70 Meter.
Aber ich finde es problematisch diese Aussage der Normalität auf Menschen anzuwenden,
denn statistisch betrachtet habe ich
gerade einem Drittel von euch gesagt,
dass ihr unnormal groß oder klein
seid. Aber lasst mich das korrigieren:
Wir sind alle unnormal, jeder von uns
und ist kann es sogar mathematisch
beweisen. Wie der Physiker Theodore Modis
beschrieben hat, braucht es nur 36
Kategorien, die einen Menschen
beschreiben,
zum Beispiel wie groß er ist, wie viele
Freunde er hat, wie schnell er laufen kann
und so weiter.
Die Wahrscheinlichkeit, dass man in allen
36 Kategorien normal ist,
beträgt 1 : 1.000.000
Und ich kann mir ohne Mühe 100
Kategorien ausdenken, die Menschen
beschreiben, es ist also mathematisch gesehen
vollkommen unnormal normal zu sein.
Paradoxon? Aber viele wissenschaftliche
Studien deuten auch darauf hin, dass
"besonders sein" besser ist als "normal
sein". Auch wenn das bedeutet, dass man von
vielen eher abgelehnt wird.
Auch das klingt paradox, aber lasst es
mich kurz erklären:
Stellt euch eine online Datingseite vor.
Durch das hohe Angebot an potenziellen
Partnern ist man leicht überfordert
jede einzelne Option in Erwägung zu
ziehen.
Im Umkehrschluss bedeutet das fürs
eigene Profil, dass man seine
ungewöhnlichen und vielleicht sogar
seine oft ungeliebten Merkmale
herausstellen sollte. Klar verringert man
die Anzahl der Interessenten damit
erst mal, denn nur die wenigsten Leute
wären gerne mit jemandem zusammen der,
sagen wir mal Spinnen als Haustiere hält,
aber diejenigen die soetwas besonders
interessant finden, sehen sofort, dass es
sich hier um einen Spinnen-Liebhaber handelt
und so geht man für diese wenigen
wichtigen Menschen nicht in der Masse unter.
Okay, vielleicht habt ihr keine Spinnen als
Haustiere, aber das Prinzip lässt sich
eigentlich auf alles anwenden. Wo
weicht ihr von der Norm ab? Was macht euch
besonders? Seid ihr der allergrößte Star
Wars-Fan auf der Welt, spielt
professionell Triangel oder seid Hobby-Botaniker? Stellt diese Besonderheiten in
den Vordergrund!
Auch wenn es unlogisch wirkt, wenn er
ehrlich seid, findet ihr viel schneller
die Menschen, mit denen ihr wirklich etwas
anfangen könnt. Aber passt auf, mit
welchen Worten ihr euch beschreibt, denn
ihr könntet aus Versehen ein weiteres
Paradoxon kreieren. Autologische
Wörter sind Wörter, die sich selber beschreiben.
"Dreisilbig" zum Beispiel ein dreisilbiges Wort, "kleingeschrieben" wird kleingeschrieben
und "achtzehnbuchstabig"
hat 18 Buchstaben. Heterologische
Wörter hingegen beschreiben nicht sich
selbst, "Englisch" ist leider nicht
englisch, sondern deutsch
"neu" ist kein neues Wort, denn man
benutzt er schon seit Jahrhunderten und
"umgangssprachlich" ist alles andere als
Slang sondern reinstes Hochdeutsch. Aber was
für ein Wort ist "heterologisch"? "heterologisch" ist ein Paradoxon.
Egal wie man es versucht einzuordnen,
wenn man davon ausgeht, dass es ein
heterologisches Wort ist, sich also nicht
selber beschreibt würde, dann müsste
es autologisch sein, um seiner
Definition zu entsprechen.
Geht man aber davon aus, dass das autologisch ist, sich also selber beschreibt,
dann ist die Definition von "heterologisch"
aber, dass es sich eben nicht selber beschreibt.
Paradoxon! Der nächste Satz ist eine
Lüge.
Der letzte Satz war die Wahrheit. Kann ein
allmächtiger Gott einen Stein erschaffen,
den er nicht selber heben kann?
Und könnt ihr den Like-Button drücken?
Ne, im Ernst, könnt ihn wirklich drücken?
Um das zu tun, müsste sich eure
Hand zum Button bewegen,
aber um das zu schaffen, müsste sie
erst mal die Hälfte der Strecke
zurücklegen. Wenn ihr das geschafft habt,
müsst ihr wieder die Hälfte der
Strecke zurücklegen und danach wieder
die Hälfte davon. Ihr müsst eine
unendliche Anzahl von Schritten
erledigen, könnt ihr es also jemals
schaffen? Schreibt mir eure liebsten Paradoxa
unten in den Comments, ansonst bin ich weg.
Haut rein!
- euer Cedric